(spoon clanging)
(light soft music)
(light upbeat music)
- Hi.
(clapping)
- Thank you, this next song
is about falling in love.
(light soft music)
♫ I sleep at night
♫ I'm falling hard
♫ For the way you love
Hey thanks for coming.
- Yeah I didn't even
know you we're playing.
- My gosh you we're so awesome.
- Oh thank you.
- Alright I'll see you at school tomorrow.
- See you.
- My ride is here.
- Do you mind splitting?
I'm going the same direction.
- Yeah sure.
(techno music)
- Um that was fun.
- Oh yeah tonight, yeah she was so good.
- Yeah I really liked it.
- Yeah it was fun.
(light soft music)
- Hey.
- You we're really great last night.
- Oh thank you.
(upbeat music)
- Um there's actually a band
playing at that same bar.
Since you like music and all,
would you wanna go together?
- Yeah sounds lovely.
(upbeat music)
- Um would you wanna go out sometime?
- Yeah.
- Sweet.
(upbeat music)